what's going on guys this is rob and a
lot of you guys have asked me to cover
some dc content honestly i'm waiting for
the current batman ark to finish just
because i found it difficult to follow
uh by trying to go video by video and
then the current joker arc just finished
so i was gonna cover that but outside of
those two things there's not a lot of
stuff that dc's covering at the moment
are doing at the moment that i'm super
interested in but maybe i should go back
and and do like a little more reading
because you know things have changed and
so on but having said that i did come
across this story which is really really
really cool right so what this does is
this initially opens up with the origin
of superman now bear with me here bear
with me right you know that i know i
know what you're thinking right oh god
another man bear with me for a second
because this story gets great it was a
terrible way to open it but the story
gets great so basically like it's the
traditional origin of superman right
this idea that like krypton is coming to
an end and nobody would listen to jorel
and that ultimately you know krypton is
doomed to destruction right so like the
rocket ship basically ends up taking off
and it crash lands on earth there's a
big difference here one difference is
that the rocket doesn't land in the
modern era on earth and the second
difference is that it's not really
kal-el who is in the ship so much as
superman and his parents right because
his mom hasn't given birth to him yet
and so it's one of those things because
when when this happens right i mean as
you guys know humanity like a thousand
years ago we're basically dumb and so
because of that
like as soon as this happens they don't
know what to make of it and they
immediately attack it right that's kind
of a sign of an idiotic human right like
they immediately attack the things they
don't understand and so because of this
uh where you end up having like all
these arrows fired off by these guys on
horseback that suddenly jorel's powers
activate and when they do he i mean of
course he incinerates the arrows but he
also incinerates everybody else
he annihilates them all using his heat
vision right and then of course in that
time period kal-el is born and in effect
like it just sort of leaves this kind of
just huge vacant place and so what you
end up doing is basically transitioning
to a place called the kingdom of storms
now in this place you have what is in
effect john constantine but you have
this prophecy that's made right this
prophecy says they have stepped onto our
world from theirs the green man waits
fire and blood gods are born and gods
are killed castles crumble people tear
as easily as parchment swifter than a
crossbow bolt more powerful than the
castle walls soaring over moats and
fortifications look up in the sky and
then it's like when the questions asked
what did you know what did you see the
response of constantine is i saw our end
right now here's the other thing too
right this castle of storms is led by
jefferson pierce we'll talk about him in
a minute but i'll be honest with you
guys he looks exactly like black panther
and i'm not even gonna lie like there
was one point where i was reading this
comic and like literally there's a big
segment where you focus on the kingdom
of storms and i was like man i feel like
i'm reading a black panther comic like
just the way he looks right jefferson
pierce looks amazing don't get me wrong
like he looks you know looks absolutely
awesome but at that point you jump
forward by 19 years right in what is now
referred to as the castle of l right so
obviously that castle off in the
distance jorrell and basically the
family of superman took it over the
other part of this is that bruce wayne
resides here and bruce wayne of course
basically shows up and when when
superman comes out to meet him right
when cal comes out to meet him the two
of them are having you know of course a
kind of conversation of course you know
bruce is basically on his way out to
deal with what's referred to as
essentially a kind of like witch right
like a banshee is basically what he
refers to this person as and then of
course when the question's asked by by
calalle hey can i come with you you know
it's like no i mean you know it's it's a
person of magic you know and you know
things like that he's like i mean come
on dude like you're just a regular human
guy like i mean i've got powers right so
at this point the abilities of superman
are not hidden they're not unknown uh
really to like the people in the
immediate kingdom and in fact it is a
thing known to people across the entire
earth at this point in time and it's one
of those moments where superman's like i
mean come on dude like look you know are
you telling me that you are not in
danger that you're somehow immune to
magic or something along those lines and
of course bruce as always gives him a
stare right rides off and then alfred of
course who's there is like that stair he
gave you man that's that's the stair he
gives when he lost an argument and so
what you end up doing is basically
switching over to the what looks like
the feist village i think is how you
pronounce that and it's one of those
things where it's like at this point in
time in effect you have what are what
are basically robin's who really really
seem more like the maybe field marshals
to a degree of uh of bruce himself right
i mean it's cool to see right you
basically got uh you got dick grayson
you've got duke uh that kind of thing
there doesn't really seem to be
any i guess references or any kind of a
comparison to the closeness that bruce
has had to these different robins over
the years so there doesn't really seem
to be an indication that like you know
dick grayson stands above the other
robbers right he's like his lead robin
or anything along those lines it's just
they are people who are here right and
that's that's essentially it now of
course once they actually get to this
inn uh where this banshee is residing of
course we basically find out it is this
alternate reality's equivalent of black
canary right which is cool because it's
one of those things where because of the
nature of the ability of magic seemingly
the family of superman is as vulnerable
to magic in this alternate reality as
they are in the main dc universe that
people with magical abilities are not
allowed in the kingdom and that if
somebody is in the kingdom who does have
magical abilities that they're usually
rounded up and they're arrested and
that's basically it now the other part
of this is that batman says magic and
your kind are outlawed in this kingdom
so seemingly it's not just people who
can use magic it's also people with
powers right people with abilities and
so again basically he tells her like you
know you're you you will be treated less
harshly
you will be tortured less if you uh if
you agree to come quietly and at that
point she basically lets off her scream
right you know her her canary cry and
when that happens the crazy thing is
around this entire area the question she
has is like how are you still alive
right like why are you not torn to
pieces and even batman himself doesn't
fully know right and of course she uses
her canary cry yet again which seemingly
almost incapacitates him and that of
course is when calallen shows up on the
scene and then basically subdues black
canary and the two of them end up taking
her to what's basically their prison now
at this point it's a series of like
small little cameos for example like you
learned that like harley quinn seems to
be here and harley quinn is really just
sort of a court jester that's really all
she is she doesn't really seem to be
anything more than that and in fact over
the course of this she'll really appear
in a lot of ways as a comedic relief but
the other part is this is what's really
really cool here is of course the father
of superman and his mother sit on the
throne for the kingdom of elf and so by
and large the argument here seems to be
they didn't want superman going out
there or at least they didn't want
cattle going out there because they
wanted to keep him protected right keep
him protected from like the dangers of
the world so there seems to be a lot
more going on here than anything else
the other part of this is that we're not
really given a lot of information about
uh about thomas and martha wayne instead
all we know is that seemingly they were
the ones who who ran the kingdom before
basically superman's parents showed up
here and that they have taken in bruce
wayne as basically their ward and that
he's as much a part of the family as
anybody else is now again the the the
details are a little sketchy here right
they're they're not really hugely
forthcoming and so what you end up
getting is a kind of argument that
breaks out between uh between bruce and
and you know cal-el not a great big huge
one right it's really more of this idea
of like you know whether or not bruce's
representative is like an actual member
of the family and different things along
those lines and that you know while he
would nest well he would kind of be like
the heir for the new kingdom the reality
is that with superman's parents on the
throne and basically bruce's parents
essentially out of the picture he no
longer has and has an entitlement to the
throne but beyond that even if the
family of superman are like you're you
know this kingdom is as much yours as it
is ours the reality is that he would be
seen as a bastard right as like a the
non-biological child of these of this
king and queen so he wouldn't really be
treated to the same level of respect by
the people in the kingdom as like khalil
would and it's one of those things where
kal-el's like i mean look man it doesn't
matter right like that's not relevant
what's relevant is you are as much a
part of this family as anybody else but
the truth is that as far as bruce wayne
is concerned he was like our our
traditions are rooted right they are
steeped here and we live and die by them
right so i mean at the end of the day
like it's one of those where it's kind
of like hey man i appreciate what you're
saying but you're wrong it's like okay i
appreciate that you're telling me that
man but i'm not wrong it's basically
that right but just like in an argument
form and so the father of superman
actually takes bruce aside and they end
up going to the top of the castle and
just kind of having a general
conversation but the big question here
is how is it that bruce wayne was able
to survive basically the whole
experience with with the black canary
right how is he able to live through
that now kind of a sidetrack for a
second this is a really important thing
while that's going on you've got hob
force which is in effect the green arrow
right like oliver queen that's basically
where this guy is now oliver queen
despite how accurate he is and despite
how capable he is he's not good enough
to be able to fire off an arrow from
seemingly miles away and be able to hit
its target but his arrow is actually
imbued and altered by the power of the
green man right we know of course now
that the green man is basically the
green lantern but it's one of those
things because what oliver says is this
makes me uneasy right it feels cowardly
dishonorable but the green man simply
responds the rings spoke to me oliver
this is how the world is safe and when
oliver asks like you're sure that this
will work the green man simply responds
it will make the distance the magic will
do the rest only your aim is in question
to which of course oliver replies my
aim's never in question but he basically
fires off the arrow now switch back over
to jorel having this conversation with
bruce wayne he says you knew you were a
bastard that was never hidden from you
or the kingdom thomas and martha had too
much misplaced honor for that and he
says you are not a mistake but what
martha and i did was and basically he
tells him you are my son bruce right
essentially martha wayne and jorel had
an affair and bruce is basically the
result of that affair but before any
other details can be forthcoming the
arrow of oliver queen meets his target
and catches jorel right in the eye and
basically kills him seemingly the era
was imbued with kryptonite energy and it
killed jorel so now he's basically dead
and batman is pissed now at that point
what's kind of crazy about this is he
literally gets the red eyes so what this
looks like between the whole thing with
black canary and this moment right here
where like his eyes are glowing red is
that bruce has at least half the power
of jorel right he's partly kryptonian in
terms of his physiology he's really
close to like jonathan kent basically
right the biological son of superman in
the main dc universe or at least the
biological son of superman and lois in
the main dc universe right he's half
human have kryptonia and so that's crazy
because now it explains why he was able
to do what he was able to do at that
point you basically switch over to him
just kind of jumping off grabbing alfred
and saying like like the the the king
like joe rel has been shot the arrow
came from hob forest and when the
question's asked how could it have
traveled so far his response is the
green man right so seemingly the green
man has been here for quite a while now
another arrow is fired and of course
batman's basically able to catch it and
keep alfred from being killed and then
at that point he sets upon oliver queen
right they're there like instantly right
they're there so fast they catch up to
oliver queen and then basically beat the
crap out of him and then essentially
take him prisoner and then at that point
you switch over to the kingdom of storms
and essentially you have the green man
who appears to john constantine and says
like it is done right so basically all
this really seems to be tied back to the
prophecy that for whatever reason it's
been taken as an absolute truth the
prophecy at the beginning of the story
heralded the arrival of like jorel and
those guys and they would basically lead
to the ruin of all and the only way to
basically save the world is to kill them
right so basically this is like this is
this is a concerted effort among like
the green man and like jefferson pierce
right basically this reality's version
of black lightning and like john
constantine to take out and to kill
jorel now another part of this it's not
going to seem overly important right now
but it will be later essentially what
looks like the children of jefferson
pierce right like anissa and so on and
so forth that basically his kids have
managed to find a way to utilize the
power of the lightning in different ways
but more so than that it's actually his
son jacob who basically has found a way
to harness the power of the rain but
basically between all of them they
manipulate the weather right so it's a
really really cool element to like the
whole mythos of jefferson pierce now
what this also does is it gives a little
more i guess maybe credence is the right
word to like the severity of the
prophecy that was made by constantine
and this whole idea here right the
reason why people are starting to look
at the kingdom of elf and they see it as
a credible threat really comes from
jefferson pierce when he says everybody
with any kind of like magical ability in
their kingdom has disappeared and
anybody who has a magical ability that's
wandered into their kingdom has
disappeared as well right for what is
basically a family that passes
themselves off as like a as a caring and
noble uh kingdom you know family out
there they seem to be doing some pretty
uh pretty heinous things but make no
mistake all of this is basically rooted
in fear but back in the kingdom of l you
have general amanda waller right and
when the question is asked like what
should we do the response of amanda
waller is jefferson pierce has to be
behind this it can't be anybody else but
him who else would have a desire to
destroy the house of l and would have
the means to do it but ultimately there
doesn't seem to be any definitive
evidence to tie jefferson pierce to this
and the fear of like kal-el and his mom
and the other members as part of the
inner court of the house of l is that if
they strike at jefferson pierce if they
launch an attack at the kingdom of
storms and it turns out they're wrong
they will instigate all-out war against
the wrong person and it would just lead
to a catastrophic set of events and so
because now the question's like okay
like if that's not the case then what do
we do here right like what do we do in
this situation do we do nothing do we
simply just like wait for evidence right
and ultimately the response seems to be
at least as far as as calallen's
concerned is that you know bruce is not
officially a part of this family
remember calallen doesn't know the truth
about bruce wayne but it's like we don't
know you know he's not a part of our
family this is for our family to decide
right he is not one of us and so in the
end basically kyle makes a call and
saying i want evidence before we launch
an attack if we go or if we're gonna
launch a strike against jefferson pierce
i want irrefutable concrete evidence
that he was the one who did it bring
that to me and we will give you your war
general waller that's basically what he
says right it's just one of those one of
those really really cool things now at
that point you switch over to amazon
island right because remember entangling
alliances so the biggest concern here is
that when the time comes or if the time
comes that they go to war with the
kingdom of storms their allies are going
to come to their aid and then the allies
of the kingdom of storms is going to
come to their age right it's how you end
up with a global war right it's how
world war one started world war ii
started right entangling alliances right
treaties and things like that and so
switching over again to to amazon island
here there's a couple things going on
right one you have wonder woman but
seemingly what you also have here is
kara jorel right she's referred to as
zala jorel but basically this is
supergirl right and she's told like your
father has been killed and so after
sharing a kind of intimate moment with
uh with wonder woman once that happens
she basically races off and it's one of
those things is because when the
questions ask like was it king pierce
the response of of of literally lois
lane right who is essentially like an
emissary in amazon amazon island it's
like we don't know for sure right it
would make the most sense that it was
him he's the most obvious target but we
don't definitively know but regardless
like when everything when she takes off
and literally everybody gets out there
you end up switching over to oliver
queen who of course is being guarded by
like bruce and harley and is being
visited by like kal-el now here's the
thing right kal-el is like move aside
and bruce is like no no no i totally get
your pissed off man but like no and it's
like stand aside and so ultimately bruce
moves and when harley asks the question
like i don't think it's really a great
idea for like us to be left alone the
response of of calallen is like it's not
a real it's not a suggestion like i am
ordering you to do this right and this
basically makes them leave now during
that time and it's not really the
conversation between like harley and and
and bruce that's overly important here
it's actually what's going on in the
background that people like the flash
and it looks like barry allen although
it could be jay garrick uh the blue
devil right king shark all these people
out there even detective chimp right all
these characters that we're familiar
with from dc comics in some form or
fashion have seemingly been rounded up
by like the house of elf and they have
been taken prisoner for either having
powers uh in the kingdom of l or having
powers and entering the kingdom of elk
but however you slice it right these
folks have all basically been rounded up
now the other thing about this is that
in this conversation between kal-el and
oliver queen that it's one of those
things where it's like yes this was
basically done on like a prophecy right
and and the the whole thing is like when
when calallen says like my father was
like a good man the response of oliver
is is that truly is that what you truly
believe right you think he was a man he
was no man at all and then he says you
are not a man right you're a monster and
you've told yourself a very convincing
lie you're a destroyer now hurry up and
kill me let's get this over with and the
response of catalan was like i'm not
going to kill you and the question is
asked why he says because i am not lying
to myself we are not what you think we
are and so at that point you switch over
to jefferson pierce now this is a crazy
moment that goes on here right jefferson
pierce here's just what sounds like this
explosion in one part of the building
and when he gets over there basically
supergirl's got his son jacob just just
like literally floating out there in the
in the air and when he's like put my kid
down she's like yes that's a great idea
she flies out there into the sky and
drops him to his death and then at that
point like literally jacob's just like
jacob's is seemingly dead jefferson
pierce loses it and then attacks cara
and then when that happens she just kind
of laughs and says like it tickles and
then flies off right so the cool thing
about this is that basically supergirl
is becoming like the dark and villainous
version that you saw and like when when
dc did the new 52 and she became like a
red lantern like that kind of a thing
right it's really really awesome now
another thing that goes on here and this
is where the plot sort of thickens a
little bit is that in this whole
conversation that you end up having
right where it's kind of like bruce
basically talking to like the the inner
court and essentially saying like you
know i knew like we need to go see like
the the house of magnus right or at
least go to the lands of magnus where
the metal men reside that kind of a
thing gather evidence and so on and so
forth do some investigating and whatnot
one of the things that happens is they
talk about the nature of like prophecies
and whatnot and superman says like it's
simply just a superstition right i come
from a planet that doesn't have
prophecies and the response of hardly is
yeah but like your planet blew up right
so maybe it's not necessarily the best
example but one of the the reason why
this matters here is because seemingly
the idea that like clark uh or at least
kal-el is like from another planet right
that like jorel and his wife are from a
different planet they're basically
aliens on earth is seemingly known to
the people here now how well it's known
to like everybody else we don't
necessarily know i mean just by the by
the nature of the statements made by
oliver queen seemingly everybody else
knows right that like they know that
like like basically superman as parents
they're not from earth but nonetheless
they exist here and their existence
essentially seems to lead to the ruin of
everything by virtue of the prophecy
that was made so that's what's kind of
interesting here is because when you do
kind of pick up with the metal men
obviously they're all basically killed
by uh by supergirl and so once you end
up having like bruce and all these guys
who show up on the scene they end up
discovering what is an effect just like
a huge amount what's what's basically
the wreckage of everything that like
supergirl's been doing not only that
they of course also stumble across some
green kryptonite and that bruce
basically begins the process of like
succumbing to this green kryptonite and
so that's kind of the crazy thing right
he sort of begins to get really really
really dizzy you know a little a little
nauseous to a degree right and he tells
alfred like it didn't affect you and
alfred says no it didn't and then in
turn bruce says like i think it hurt
because of who i am who i really am
alfred i need to tell you and in turn
alfred says it's all right son i know i
know all of it and it's time that you
learned the truth about yourself bruce
wayne so that's where this story ends
because technically this is only the
first three issues and apparently it was
so ridiculously popular that dc actually
repackaged it as like the gathering
storm and called it a day so we gotta
wait until march 1st i think for uh for
the next issue to come out so yeah let
me know what you guys think about this
story right i mean this story is just
ridiculously good but let me know what
you guys think down in the comments
section thank you all for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace